I'm old enough to remember December 31st
2000 fact I wrote an op-ed that appeared
in the New York Times the very next day
it was about the coming of the year 2001
and what would surely be the incessant
comparisons people would make with the
film 2001 itself made in 1968 so finally
the future had arrived
what's the checklist how are we doing
okay
they had a space station under
construction in 2001 so so did we check
they had a moon colony no we didn't have
a moon colony they hadn't yet been to
Jupiter we had been to Jupiter not with
humans but with our robotic emissaries
space probes the Pioneer 10 and 11
Voyager 1 and 2 these are spacecraft
launched from Earth with enough velocity
to escape the solar system entirely once
it accumulated gravitational assists
from planets that happen to be lined up
with its path as it didn't happen to be
lined up we set it up that way these are
space probes that went into these into
the space of these outer planets
it took images it studied the clouds it
looked at the magnetic fields we knew
more about the outer solar system in
2001 then the film did a couple of other
interesting factors back then they
imagine that if a room sized computer
was of a given smarts then a spaceship
size computer would be even smarter it's
like what this is the two thousand
powers computers are small they're not
large in fact they're so small you carry
them around with you that was
unthinkable in 2000 in 1968 unthinkable
and so I think we're doing better in
some cases yeah I know we all wanted the
moon base and things and maybe that'll
still come I think it ought to still
come but
I think we did well with our robotic
emissaries we had to be exploiting that
solar system vicariously and that's okay
we know how to do that we we all know
how to use a joystick and but I was
still long to go there myself that's
still one of my goals if not for me then
for others in the nation or in the world